All right, let's do it.
Yup. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
This is more perfect mini series
about the Supreme Court and um,
today's story from a reporter.
Shawn always eff up your last name.
Can you just say it?
Ramas from Ramez from,
I always put the accent in
the morning place. Anyhow,
let me set the table for you. We
live in a representative democracy.
And what does that actually
mean? Practically speaking?
Like when do we come in
contact with that democracy?
Two places seems to me mainly
one when we vote, right? Yeah.
You're asking me? Yeah. I was deep
in thought if you vote, if you vote.
It's true. I know like college educated,
super progressive human beings who
are like, why would I ever vote?
It doesn't mean anything. Exactly.
Not to mention people who just don't
even care about the world. Yeah.
It sorta makes my point like
voting is the first way.
And for a lot of people it's entirely
optional. The second way is not,
you will be fine.
You don't do it. And I mean serving
on a jury. This is where like we,
the people decide who goes
to jail, who gets free,
who lives, who dies.
This is where we actually
do democracy today. Uh,
we start with the story of a guy who
supreme, who is Supreme Court famous,
would you say? Yeah, he's in the
books. He's like a chapter. Yeah.
He's like one of the most important names
you've never heard of because he's at
the center of this ongoing battle about
who gets to serve on juries and his name
depending on who you are,
either symbolizes the best parts of
American democracy or the most cynical,
should I say his name? Yeah, go for
it. James Batson. James Kirkland.
That's, Hello
James.
I went to his house in Northville.
Tell me your full name and tell me
where you're from and that James Batson,
Louisville, Kentucky, James Batson,
his name just kept coming up over and
over again when I was looking through the
history of jury selection in America.
So I called him up and I was like, Hey,
I'm this radio reporter in New York City
and I'm really interested in your case
because there's this other case
before the court right now.
Could I come talk to you? And he's,
he was like, oh, yeah, sure. Okay,
make sure my full name and shitty
mentioned. Of course he's tall,
he's built like a fridge. Um,
he's a black man. Drove a truck,
local and cross country far from
being business 15 hours one way.
Where was that? Florida as a kid.
He was, he was an aid student.
Graduated from her and technical
high school, Hughes, uh, you know,
like vocational school, specializing
in electrical engineering,
industrial electricity.
He seemed pretty popular,
perfect tennis water Sunday
school when I was 18,
but shortly after that it
seemed like the bottom fell out.
[inaudible]
James Batson grew up in the West End of
Louisville in the 1970s and the west end
was super rough. People
selling dope prostitution, uh,
just everything had to do with
past money at a young age.
Fast money was like the American dream. I,
it's pretty hard when a lot of people
around you got nice things and they got
them because they're doing something
illegal and you keep coming up with rabid
error to shaking your head like you
know [inaudible] you pull both of your
pockets out and ain't nothing
to neither one of them.
He said it all started when he
was 10 he wanted a pair of shoes.
He couldn't afford them. Chuck
Tyler's, well, when I first came out,
if you didn't have a pair of those,
you get on what they call buddies
loaded buddies, cheap tennis shoes.
Him and his brother asked
his mom for money and they,
she gave them some money but not
enough so to make up the difference.
They went out and they stole people's
empty soda bottles and turn them in for
like the deposits three sent our Nicola
piece stole the pop bottles to get Chuck
Tyler.
There was my first experience with
pure legal money stolen pop bottles,
so everything else there. Fast
forward a couple of years,
James is more grown up.
He start doing some petty crime in
and he starts breaking into houses.
They actually gave me a name,
call me to pants pocket.
Birdwell when the crime would happen,
burglar would take only stuff competing
in his pocket, like purses and jewelry.
No merchandise. He didn't fit in
his pocket. He wouldn't take it.
And that was you.
I'm not admitting that was me possible
deniability because there is two murder
names I'm asking you was
a year. I take the fields.
So James starts stealing bigger
things and he starts getting arrested,
starts going in and out of the courts
and then one of those small in and out
cases, it became, I think
American legal history.
They got me out of a car, 1982 cops
pull them over. You pull me out the car.
They said you have the right to remain
silent and anything and went through that
little protocol,
whatever they tell him some burglaries
that happened in an area and it they said
I did them. Well, you stealing
stuff. Yeah. At the time I,
I had been doing some burglaries
or whatever, but anyway,
but James said he didn't do this one
and that they didn't have the proof.
He was his driving around in
his car and they picked him up.
When they arrested me, I'm thinking they
didn't really have a case against me.
They didn't catch me
breaking into a house.
You got me out of the car
in no fingerprints, no
where he thinks he can win.
I feel like I could beat case. So I'm
like, I want a jury trial and I'm,
the mere fact that you and I are talking
about James Bateson's case 30 plus
years later is amazing.
That's the prosecutor. My name is Joe
Guttman. I'm from Louisville, Kentucky.
Uh, grew up in Louisville,
raised in Louisville wanting to
be a lawyer since he was a kid.
My parents went through a divorce when
I was very young and I wanted to go to
law school to help kids and divorces 1982
when Joe Guttman first gets the Batson
case, he's 26 years old and
had just become a lawyer. Uh,
James's case was in the first six months
that I was in the prosecutor's office.
Pretty impressive. Uh, first year. Um, no,
starting out. I lost my first
eight trials. Really? Yeah. This is
when it's our Bateson's case. You know,
this low level burglary of breaking
of a house in a purse being stolen.
He was like, oh, maybe this'll be my,
when the evidence appeared that
he was guilty of the crime,
James was accused and identified
as the one who's having done it.
Two eye witnesses. They're saying
James did it, but James is saying,
no I didn't. You don't have any proof.
He says the cops probably showed these
witnesses photos of him before because
that you need never seen
them before in his life. So,
so governments on the case, it goes
to trial and he had a hung jury.
They ended up being a hung jury.
It means they couldn't come to a
unanimous decision. So James gets off.
Why was it a hung jury? Well, in Kentucky
you have to have a unanimous verdict.
So the defense is looking for that
one juror that keeps from convicting.
There is apparently one
juror who just didn't buy it,
didn't buy the evidence and thought
James was legit. It was a black woman.
One black lady came to visit me after
the jury was over. She said, I really,
really don't think you're guilty.
The rest of the jury was trying to make
me say that she was guilty and I was
saying not guilty. So
ended up being a hung jury.
That was disappointed at that point I
was having second thoughts about um,
you know, is this the right career for me?
So Joe Guttman, he says, I'm going
to try this case one more time.
It was pretty close to guilty. I
had this one juror who hung it up.
So let me do it one more time.
And he does something this
time a little differently
just to set it up. As you know, when
you get a jury summons, you go in,
you're on a jury pool, and at the
beginning of a trial all rise.
Jurors please stand and raise your
right hand. You have jury selection.
Unh of you do solemnly swear or affirm
that you will true answers tonight to
such questions as may be asked you
touching your call if the cat's with both
sides, the prosecution, the
defense, sometimes the judge,
they get jurors into a room and
they start asking lots of questions.
Is there anyone here who's been the
victim of a crime? Have you needed,
you had family members that have
been victims of crime. Okay.
I saw a couple of hands. They
start interviewing jurors.
Do you have any opinions one way or the
other about the criminal justice system
in general to figure out which
jurors do we want the [inaudible]?
I do remember you're involved
in any organizations.
I'm the member of a church.
Which jurors do we want to get rid of and
that's the more important part of this
process. Which jurors do we
want to toss off this jury pool?
So what are the rules
to get rid of jurors?
There's two ways to get rid of jurors
to get down to that group of 12 in this
case. And the first way is called striking
for cause the state would move to,
excuse him for cause at this time striking
for cause is like when they ask you
can you be fair in this case if you
say, you know, no I really can't.
I have really strong feelings about
the people or the subject matter.
That's a strike for cause. Or it's like,
hey that lady who's sitting in the
chair, the defendant that's um,
that's my cousin. We grew up together.
No, like conflict of interest.
Convolutions that's my boss. We'd
go out every Saturday for brunch.
Whatever it is. You're too close
to this. You can't be fair. Got It.
So that one's, cause that's
pretty much common sense.
It makes sense to everyone.
But the second way is the heart of
this whole matter. This whole story.
It's called a peremptory
challenge. Preemptory or not?
Peremptory peremptory that's a word.
Depending on how you punch it into Google,
it will be like, that's a type
of a son. What does it mean?
What does peremptory mean?
Peremptory challenge means you get a
certain number of strikes just to get rid
of people you think
might not be fair to you,
but you can really use them anyway
you want. And with these strikes,
you don't have to give any reason.
Wow. And how many of these do you get?
So it varies from state to state. In
some states it's 20 and other states,
that's four in Kentucky then and now each
side gets eight eight jurors that they
just get to put the excellent and so
you're not going to sit on this trial hook
or crook and they don't have
to explain themselves at all.
They don't have to explain anything.
And this isn't just some weird legal
rule we made up like 20 years ago.
This is something that has been
around. It's older than America.
He goes back to England
in the 11th 12th century.
And before that some say it goes back
to like one oh four BC Roman times.
Really, really? And the idea is, I feel
like the visualization is like a seesaw.
Like okay, we need to get to
this perfect group of 12 people.
And you know there's going to be
people who are biased either side.
So each side gets to eliminate
people. You get three, you get three,
you get four,
you get four and then we'll come to
this balance in the jury of a group of
people who are going to be fair.
So if both sides are sort of trying
to tilt it their way from either side,
the thinking is it'll
end up balanced. Yeah.
And also the thinking was that this
would give both sides more faith in the
process and at the same time protect both
sides from like the tyranny of a trial
judge who has too much
power. Gotcha. Okay.
And what happens in this case
is the second trial begins.
So take me into the moment of jury
selection, which is I imagine early in,
that's the first thing that
happens. Set a scene. Well,
the only people that were in the
courtroom were some family members and Mr
Bateson, his attorney, a
detective and me and the jury.
So the reason we're talking about this
case and Joe Guttman and James Batson is
because the next thing that happens
is Joe Guttman gets up there,
he scans the jury pool. And at this
point he says there were 13 people left,
four that were black,
nine that were white.
And he uses his peremptory
challenges to strike off. One, two,
three, four black
jurors. They're all gone.
Leaving an all white shirt.
Do you remember striking four minority
people off this jury? Uh, well,
uh, I mean I did a, do I specifically
remember the reason for each?
Uh,
no adult I asked Joe was the reason
because they were in fact black.
No, I can see that they were
not stricken because of race.
And I remember specifically that one of
the jurors lived in the neighborhood.
He doesn't exactly remember what his
reasons were for all four black jurors.
But what's important for our story is to
know that James Batson is sitting there
in the room as all of this is happening.
And I'm like, ah,
just completely struck out of blacks
off the jury pool. It ain't right.
And I told my lawyer, I said, you
objected that they, you know, lawyer says,
why would I object? James said,
because it's not fair. He said, no,
that's a longstanding rule.
He's allowed to do that and you
can strike what would be wrong.
Was he loyal white or was he black?
He was white. Judge white or black.
He was white.
And aside from those four people that
had just been struck off the jury,
everybody in the courtroom was white.
So again, told my lawyer to object. And
again, the lawyers says, he said, no,
you, I've told you you can't object to
this. So what do you mean you can't,
you work for me. You do what? I say.
You just object anyway. I don't care.
This longstanding rule object,
he did it all came behind
that one. Objection.
It's one tiny moment. Yeah.
What happened is after the
jury was selected, Doug Dale,
James, his attorney said, judge,
how I want to make an objection.
Uh, we went up to the
bench. He said, your honor,
you can see there's an all white jury.
I would like for him
to explain his strikes,
but before I could get another word
out of my mouth, Judge Ryan said,
Mr Gutman does not have to explain his
rights. It's not the law. Let's move on.
Move on. So they moved on with an all
white jury and I got found guilty.
They get 20 years. Hmm. For Burglary? Yes.
So Batson goes to prison,
Danville, Kentucky,
and he says his first move when
he got there or po immediately.
And ultimately his appeal ends
up in the hands of this guy,
David Niehaus, Jefferson county
public defender's office.
And the house decides to
do something ambitious.
What we did is we call it and
taking a tour of the jurisdictions,
Washington Gallup barn in [inaudible].
It takes a legal road trip to me house
and his team start looking at other
states, looking at other regions to find
out what this is a problem elsewhere.
Is this just something limited to
the south or is it something else?
Do you mean like are people
in other places doing what?
Joe got mid dead and using peremptories
to kick black people off a jury's
[inaudible]. Right. And what he
found is that this was happening.
Sounds ideal and I need to check
in Indiana, Kentucky, Ohio,
pretty much everywhere.
So they filed an appeal which worked
its way up through the courts.
And in December, 1985 thank you gentleman.
Locations submitted hear arguments
year in a battle against Kentucky.
The case arrives at the Supreme
Court of the United States.
I get a call one day from the Associated
Press. That's Joe Guttman saying,
how do you feel about the Supreme Court
accepting the case of James Kirkland?
Vanson and I was almost speechless.
And where you sitting on the bench? Uh,
I did, uh, go just to observe and learn
district main hundred sign thinking
your proceeding whenever you're ready.
Thank you your honor. Mr Chief
Justice and may it please the court.
So here's that ultimately went down,
that's inside me house.
He argues that these strikes are being
used to take black people off of juries.
And this was happening everywhere.
We were able to list some 25 jurisdictions
and that the practice violated the
14th amendment, which was equal
protection. And the sixth amendment,
which was a right to a jury of your peers,
a jury that is as representative
of the community as possible.
So if Louisville is like 17% black,
the jury should probably be about 17%
black and the prosecutors shouldn't just
be allowed to skew that without
having to give a reason. First of all,
Kentucky's response to require an
explanation of peremptory challenges would
destroy,
we believe the historical nature and
function of the device itself until
Kentucky saying, we shouldn't
have to justify these strikes.
The court has told us
that again and again.
It has always been unfettered
and controlled by the
court unexplained and this
practice goes back centuries and
yes, there may be some abuses,
but this is a tool that lawyers need.
Thank you gentleman. The case
is submitted four months later,
the court delivers its verdict
and in a seven to two decision
that's and when the court found that the
prosecutor's actions for sure violated
the 14th amendment.
They said racial discrimination of any
kind in jury selection is not allowed.
Q Dan Rather. The high court rule
today is illegal totes illegal.
Even on a peremptory challenge.
It is illegal for a lawyer to reject
the juror on the basis of rights.
James Batson sentence was immediately
vacated. How'd that feel? Okay,
it's undescribable.
If you were in prison and you know
your sentence is being taken away,
I mean that's great feeling.
I'll still break every day.
And in this conversation come up, y'all
could just be hanging out playing chess.
Oh, I got a law and the
law books Batson rule.
And that was the biggest deal of all this.
The headline there was this new rule
and rule the bats and bets and match.
And that's and rule named after him.
So justice was put new limits on
what is called preemptory challenge.
The Batson rule. The Batson rule is an
echo of what James did in court that day.
When you see people, minorities getting
booted off of a jury, you can say,
your honor, I think that's a batching
violation. That's in violation.
And then the other side be it,
the defense of the prosecution has to
provide non-racial reasons for why they
eliminated that juror. And for a lot
of people, this was a breakthrough.
This is like finally we figured
out how to do this right.
There was a system in
place to protect everyone.
And that system was even extended to
civil cases and eventually to women as
well. Uh, it was a big deal
when the case was decided.
And the initial elation was quickly
tempered with a strong dose of reality.
This is Jeff Robinson.
He's the director of the APLU Center for
justice because what bats and prevents
is deliberate racial discrimination.
And, uh, almost immediately
all over the country,
prosecutors started training each other,
teaching each other on how to get
around Bateson. That's Bryan Stevenson,
he's the director of the equal justice
initiative in Montgomery, Alabama.
I there at trainings
all across the country.
And some of these are on video
data and I found fun. I mean,
it's on Youtube when you're picking a
jewelry and you gotta stay to these basic
rules. This is one of
those videos. This one,
it's a Philadelphia prosecutor named
Jack McMahon lecturing to a room full of
young prosecutors on how to pick a jury,
you know, and in, in selecting blacks,
you don't want the real educated ones.
And my experience, black women,
young black women are very bad. Uh,
there's an antagonism, I guess maybe
cause they're downtrodden on two respects.
There they've got two minorities
or women and their blacks.
And so there are downtrod on
two areas and they somehow, uh,
want to take it out on somebody and
you don't want it to be you. And so
the craziest thing about this video is
that it was filmed just a few months
after the Batson decision.
Batson versus Kentucky. I'm sure you've
all become aware of that case. Yeah.
Jack Man basically tells
these prosecutors, look,
we've got this new rule.
Here's how you break it. You strike
the black person off the jury.
But just say it's for another reason
because that's what Batson requires is a
racially neutral.
My advice would be in that situation
is when you do have a black jury,
are you questioning them at length and
honest little sheet that you have marked
something down that you can articulate
later time if something happens.
So let's say you strike three blacks to
start with first three people write it
down right then and there. I'd write it
right in my little box there. You know,
the woman had a kid about the same age
as the defendant and I thought she'd be
sympathetic to a more,
she's unemployed and I just don't like
unemployed people because I find they're
not too stable. Quizzes
almost this training to create a catalog
of reasons that on the face where race
neutral,
just say you're excluding them because
they're too tall or they're too old. Oh,
that person was wearing a black
sweater. Things like, well,
he lives in a bad neighborhood.
Person would maintain eye contact,
their body language, where
they belong to a church,
tattoos where they're a nurse. Any of
those reasons have them marked down.
As long as a prosecutor doesn't say,
I excused that person because they're
black bats and says it's completely okay.
I was actually working on a case. Uh,
this is lawyer Bryan Stevenson again,
my office, the at the time was called
the southern prisoners defense committee.
This was, and I was in Atlanta,
Georgia before I moved to Alabama.
And when was this?
This was 1986 and we were defending
someone down in Swainsboro, Georgia,
a guy by the name of gamble. Uh, and, uh,
the Batson decision came down, uh,
and objections were made when the
prosecutor used his peremptory strikes to
exclude all of the African Americans.
And we said, wait a minute, your honor,
there's a new decision
Batson versus Kentucky,
which means that the prosecutor can't
do this. And the court said, well,
I've read Bateson.
What this means is that the prosecutor
has to give a race neutral reasons.
And so the prosecutor, I've got
my race neutral reasons is, well,
I struck this woman because she
looks just like the defendant.
That tendon was an African American
man. They said, wait a minute,
what does that she does? And the
judge said, oh, I see that. He said,
I struck judge that I see no, as
he did what the prosecutor said,
I struck this man because he lives in
south Swainsboro and that's where the
defendant lives. And we were,
of course, we say, look,
all the black people live in south
Waynesboro, all the white people,
that's not a race neutral
reason. The judge had no,
that is a race neutral reason.
He said, I struck one person, uh,
because this man was in the military and
he was discharged after five years in
the military. And in my
experience, your honor,
you only get discharged honorably after
an even number of years or the jury was
put back on the stand. We said, well,
were you discharged from the
military honorably? Yes, I was.
I was actually decorated. I got
this metal, I got this award.
I've got these things. Well,
I still accept the prosecutors
reading for excluding that person. No.
My favorite was the prosecutors.
Some of those for your phone? No,
it gets better. It gets
better. Roscoe said,
I struck this man because he testified
that he was a mason and he said,
your honor, I just don't want anybody
who's a member of a masonic lodge.
All my jury, they have their
own codes, their own rituals,
they're all in culture. I don't want that.
And the jury was put back on
this day and we asked the juror,
are you a member of a Masonic Lodge?
And the jury said, no, I'm not. He said,
I'm a brick mason. And the judge
says, I still know what you mean,
I'll let you exclude that person. Right.
And so almost from the very beginning
there was this cynicism is game playing.
I used to tell people Bateson's not
going to eliminate racial bias and jury
selection, but it will make the jury
selection process a lot more entertaining.
You all should come to court and
just watch the show. [inaudible]
that's why. So you could argue that not
only did Batson not change anything,
but that's in made things worse. Um, as
one lawyer, Steven Bright, put it to me.
I think what Batson is really is
basically a set of procedures to sort of
legitimize and cover up the race
discrimination that's going on.
You had this smelly,
putrid problem of racial discrimination
in jury selection and instead of tossing
it out, we just prayed for
breeze all over. He just
kind of perfumed it vaguely
sheep Cologne. It's still there.
It just vaguely hidden. And
now with the Batson rule,
if you think the prosecution or the
defense is striking people off because of
race,
you have to call them out and then you
have to somehow try and prove that the
reason they're providing is a lie. And
that's really, really difficult to do.
Since 1986 for example, in
the state of Washington,
there have been probably 47 48 challenges
on Batson issues where people have
been convicted and they've
said, wait a minute.
The prosecutors were excusing people of
color from the jury because they were
people of color. Out of
those 46 to 50 challenges,
there's been one reversal.
The state of Tennessee has not reversed
a single case under Bateson in the 30
years for it. It said, said the
Batson decision came down as a result.
He says there's still many counties in
America where the diversity of the jury
has not increased very much
at all. So for example,
in one Louisiana Parish,
they looked at felony cases over an eight
year period and found that nearly half
the black jurors were
struck in Houston county,
Alabama over a five year period.
The data establish that 80% of the African
Americans qualify for jury service.
We were struck
80% 80% and that's in death
penalty cases, so wow.
I mean if you think about that
like a big percentage of the time,
these are lawyers who are going around
the bats and rule going around the law
going around the constitution to get
these all white juries who are then
oftentimes pudding
black men to death and that reminds
me of some pretty dark history.
Yeah. Wow. Super basic question. Yeah.
I mean
that video training video,
the assumption in that video is it having
black people on the jury would hurt?
That guy would hurt the
prosecutor. Yeah. Is that,
should we just assume that
or I mean is there anything,
any data that would say
that's even remotely true?
The hardest thing about looking at this
stuff analytically is that juries are
like a black box.
They don't let journalists and academics
in often to study what's going on.
The jury is kind of sacred that way.
Yeah. But the few times we've gotten data,
like there's this group called the
Capitol Jury Project that looks at data
specifically in capital cases because
that's where this stuff ends up being life
or death.
So they looked at data in like 350 cases
in 14 states over a number of years and
they found that white men are more likely
to go for the death penalty than black
men.
When you get to sentencing that number
that the difference between white and
black, it's really exaggerated.
Like white men are seven times more
likely to want the death penalty than a
black person. There.
Another study that was done in Florida
and this one looked at felony cases over
like 10 years and they found that all
white jury pools in Florida can be do
black defendants 16% more often
than white defendants. Okay.
But what was really interesting is like
that that gap was practically eliminated
when at least one member of the
jury pool was black. Interesting.
You put one black person in the jury
pool and that difference is annihilated.
Yeah. And you can test the
obvious question why? I mean,
obviously criminal cases usually involve
cops and the reason that's often cited
is that you know,
black jurors are less
likely to believe cops.
Lecturers are more likely to insert
some sense of suspicion into the s the
states or the Commonwealth or
whatever his testimony. Yeah,
and almost everyone I talked to gave me
a version of this that that you know,
when you have black people on a jury,
they deliberate more and that black
people are less likely to trust law
enforcement,
especially Jack McMahon who was the
guy we heard from in that video.
Well listen,
anybody that knows me knows I am about
as the anti racist person that you could
ever imagine.
I might stone cold
liberal to the nth degree,
but I was talking about practicalities
of picking the jury back then and I still
stand by that. I mean if
you're a prosecutor, all right,
let me ask you this question. And
you're trying to drug case so to speak,
and your and your defense
and the defendant is going
to claim that the cops are
lying. Okay. And you're
the prosecutor. Now,
what demographic group has had more
exposure to police line than minority
communities?
They have seen a police lie
and will believe police lie
more than some white guy
lives in a rich area. I believe
that police officer, every time,
everything he says,
and so as a prosecutor you're trying
to win the case and that person is not
going to be a person who's going to be
more questioning of your witnesses and
you're given the opportunity through
peremptory challenges to strike them.
Why wouldn't you? You'd be a fool not to.
Well, I guess, uh, I s I see
the argument that, you know,
use your peremptory challenges to get
the best jury you can to win. Right,
but doesn't eliminating a black juror
because you believe they might have
certain biases against a police officer
versus a white teacher in some way
violate the equal protection
clause of the 14th amendment? No,
I don't think so. Not at all.
Because it's not because
of the color of their skin.
It's because of their
demographics and where the,
who they've dealt with. It's a societal
demographic concept. It's just,
it's just the fact of
life. It's just like,
but I think those facts of life and
those societal demographic [inaudible]
concepts all stem from
the color of their skin.
Oh Wow. That's it. That's it. That,
that maybe a deeper issue that we
can't deal with in jury selection. Uh,
you're right. But the reality
is the reality is that, that,
that that's what the situation, so,
so you're saying that if you're
the prosecutor, you should say, oh,
well this guy will probably
be worse. Uh, for me,
he probably believed those cops are lying,
but I'm going to take them because I
want to uphold the, you know, come on.
I mean, that's just not
realistic. That's just,
there isn't a prosecutor in a country
that would do that. Say, well, I want to,
I want to show my altruism and I'm
gonna keep this guy on my jury who may
disbelieve my essential witnesses
because I want to be out. You're Wistia.
I mean, come on. That's
just not the way life is.
[inaudible]
can we go, how to solve
a problem like Bateson?
Perfect. We'll continue in a moment.
[inaudible]
I'm Preet Bharara every week
on my podcast. Stay tuned.
I answer your questions about what's
really happening in Washington.
I wonder if it is legal for press or
the Trump to initiate military action
against North Korea.
What happens if Mueller returns an
indictment against the president?
I just want to know,
are you a table genius?
Subscribe to stay tuned
from cafe and W NYC studios.
This is more perfect mini series about
the supreme court. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Sean Ramas from
let's just for a second,
explain how we got into this whole morass
about racial bias in jury selection.
I think we should, it's because of a case.
It was in front of the Supreme Court.
Uh, this term. Yup. Will hear argument
first this morning in case 14,
83 49 foster versus
Chapman. So basic facts.
This is a murder case in Georgia.
A younger black man kills
an elderly white woman.
The prosecutors dismiss a bunch of black
jurors and the defense having this new
bets and rules says
hold up, can't do that.
And the prosecutors give these race
neutral reasons and the judge says,
that looks good to me.
And then years later something sort of
incredible happens through like one of
those freedom of
information act type things.
The defense actually gets to see the notes
the prosecution had during the trial.
The notes they kept during jury selection.
This is one of those rare times when we
pull back the curtain and we find out
what the prosecutors were doing.
This is lawyer Steven Bright.
He actually argued the foster case in
front of the Supreme Court late last year
and he says what you saw in these
notes was that the prosecution,
they literally wrote a little B next to
the name of each and every black juror B
one B two B three, uh, highlighting
all the blacks and, and,
and green on the, on the list of all
the people summoned for jury duty.
It's like race, racial discrimination
is really hard to prove.
This is actual physical
proof in a file in the state.
Like this is the smoking gun we've
been waiting for. So what did the PR,
what did the prosecutor,
how did the prosecution argued
this in front of a Supreme Court?
Prosecution was like, you know what?
Actually once the notes were found,
they said foster is,
we were just writing those bs because
we wanted to make sure we noticed the
black jurors. We wanted
to keep track of them.
The reasonable explanation in this
case is four months prior to trial,
defense counsel files a motion and
says the strike of any black juror,
we're filing a Batson challenge.
That's the lawyer representing
Georgia Beth Burton, and she's saying,
of course we're going to notice race.
This is the post Bateson world and we're
going to note race and we're going to
write it down.
I would be more surprised, quite frankly,
if there wasn't some sort of highlighting.
In other words,
the argument you're making here is that
is that the reason he highlighted all
the black jurors in green, he
being the original prosecutor, uh,
and a said a block but about the black
jurors and did all these different things
was because he was preparing a defense
in case of a Batson challenge. Correct.
That's just as prior asking, well,
why didn't you make that argument like
when the case was actually happening
years and years ago
and it was several years. Yes. So
if that had been his real reason,
why isn't it a little surprising that
he never thought of it or didn't tell
anybody until you raised this
argument in your main brief
and, and I would, I would say
that's on state habeas counsel.
Hmm.
Uh, so the good news is that
in a seven to one decision,
the Supreme Court agreed that
this prosecutor's reasons
were utterly ridiculous.
Well, it isn't. This is a,
I'm just going to ask you,
isn't this as clear about in violation
as accord is ever going to see that
Justice Kagan? I don't think it is.
The bad news is that this case was
in front of the Supreme Court at all.
It had to get appealed up to the highest
court in the land before someone said,
Oh yeah, that's [inaudible] the Batson
violation. That's how hard it is. Yeah.
And the Supreme Court though, it made a
forceful decision. Seven out of eight,
they didn't make a new rule. They
said, this isn't how it works.
They didn't try offer up a Batson 2.0 or
they didn't double down or throw it out
or do some new rule. No, they
said this is really wrong,
but they didn't go as far to say,
well clearly this doesn't work.
So we still got Bateson. Yeah,
still got Bateson. So, okay,
if we want to diverse juries and we
know that Bateson doesn't really work,
what do we do?
So I asked everyone I talked to that
question and got a lot of different
answers, but this was the obvious
one. And Nancy, Nancy Margaret,
who's a professor of law, IIT, Chicago,
Kent College of Law starts us off.
What I'd like the court to do is
eliminate peremptory challenges.
It's a no brainer again, that Steven
Bright, he's a lawyer. We have to,
I mean it's like,
it's like the Supreme Court gives you
these rules of peremptory challenges to
strike people and then says, well, wait
a minute, don't just strike people.
You know, we're gonna look into all
the ways that you strike the people.
Well then don't give them at all then
for crying out loud. It's real simple.
Even Jack McMahon, the guy from that
training video, he was open to it.
We've had 30 years of experiment
with Bateson and it's not working.
We now have to go the route that Justice
Marshall suggested back in [inaudible]
Batson. This court has never stated,
not do not speak for the constitution.
The rule in the Batson decision,
you've got Thurgood Marshall,
like the most important attorney in the
civil rights movement turned the first
Black Supreme Court justice.
He in the same paragraph
called the Batson decision,
historic and then said,
this isn't going to work.
This decision isn't going to do anything.
He was basically a fortune teller.
He said both those things in the
same breath, in one paragraph,
he started out going, this decision today,
historic by the end of the paragraph,
you're never going to fix this until
you get rid of peremptory challenges.
[inaudible] 9% to both say, just do
away with peremptory strikes. Look dead.
Fall into constitution. If
both sides are challenges,
if code says do not
[inaudible], no, sorry, will not
violate the constitution. He said,
as long as you have peremptory
challenges, you will have discrimination.
But what surprised me most in
reporting this story is that,
like I talked [inaudible] talk to
people on the left side of the criminal
justice system on the right side of the
criminal justice system, ACLU
types, law professors, academics,
conservative prosecutors, all of
these people, when you say, guys,
we've got to get rid of
peremptory challenges, right?
Almost every single one will say,
no, no, no. It's kind of cool.
That's a crucially important tool. We
made them. It is crucially important.
You know, it's an easy solution. Just
get rid of peremptories. No, hell no.
That's Ellie ms style or
legal editor, law professor,
Son Wolfe from Santa Clara University
and lawyer David Niehaus again.
And here's one of the arguments I
heard. If you take these things away,
all the decisions about striking jurors
would be made by the judge on the
question of whether the juror
could be fair and impartial.
And for that to work you have to have a
fair judge and there are an awful lot of
judges who aren't fair.
Here's another argument I heard from
Jeffrey Robinson from the ACLU and this is
based on my experience of 34 years
in the criminal justice system.
Jeff Robinson says, if you can find some
way to take race out of the equation,
peremptories are super useful and
he told me about this one case,
very high profile case in the
state of Washington.
This case was incredibly complicated
and also potentially involved a coerced
confession by some undercover cops and
there's a police officer on the jury
panel. He says, I can be fair.
I know the police officers
that investigated this case.
I've worked with them before. I
think they're really good people,
but don't worry, I can be fair.
Everything about his
background was saying,
I do not want this man to serve
on this jury, but he was saying,
I can be fair.
I could not exclude him on a challenge
for cause [inaudible] because he said he
could be fair.
The fact that he's a police
officer doesn't mean he
can't be fair but is insane.
I know some of these people involved
in this case enough to get him, uh,
dismissed for cause it's
enough to get more questioning.
But how well do you know I'm not very
well. So you're saying in that case,
if you said, okay judge,
I'd like to dismiss juror 17 for car
cause the judge would say there's not a
record per cause.
I don't think any judge in this country
would dismiss that juror for cause. Wow.
And so a peremptory
challenge is important.
So I've watched more jury selection
videos on youtube than any person ever
should. And
it's this amazing thing
where you see these people,
they're not necessarily used
to being in a courtroom.
They're certainly not used to being
grilled in public. 500 people in suits.
They get up there to the jury panel
and they get asked these questions.
Does everyone agree that bias
doesn't have any place in the trial?
Over and over again? Can you
be ferrying impartial? Yes sir.
You're like a blank slate and you
just got to listen to the evidence.
Can you do all that? Yes, I
can. Okay. Nobody Says No.
Everyone feels like yes, I
can be fair. And you know,
this is the time to tell us.
That's why we're asking you this.
I'm thinking I could, okay,
I can be totally unbiased and I think
some of them believe that they can
actually do this for nearly impossible
task and others they know they can't,
but they might say yes anyway.
Anyone who tries the case believe
me knows that bias. Jurors comment,
they don't reveal things,
they lie about things.
There's people that
when you're questioning,
I'm in a jury that you
know they're lying to you.
They're either trying to get on the
jury or trying to get off the jury bias.
People are being allowed to serve.
So any tool that can help reduce the
number of bias jurors on jurors is
essential to justice.
So yeah, if you've got a really
crappy outlook on jurors and humans,
then maybe you need more
peremptory challenges.
But the way Jeffrey Robinson put it to
me was that if you're using peremptory
challenges the right way, it forces
you to be like equal opportunity,
suspicious, suspicious of everyone.
And that's the only way to be fair.
My parents were both active in the
civil rights movement in Memphis,
Tennessee as active as two people. You
could ever want to meet both black.
I would never let my mother sit on a
criminal defense jury because my mother's
view about black defendants was you're
the reason I have to lock the door in my
neighborhood.
You're the reason that I get disrespected
when I go out into the community and
I'm going to take it out on you.
My father's position would be,
I wouldn't believe a police officer if
he told me it was raining and the water
was coming down on my head.
And so what this is about is actually
putting into effect what the rules say.
Talk to jurors and find
out what they think.
But what about Thurgood
Marshall's idea that you know,
if you have peremptory challenges, if
you give people a way to discriminate,
they will discriminate.
Well,
I was born in 1956 and so in 1954
Thurgood Marshall argued Brown versus the
board of Education,
which had a significant impact on my life.
Thurgood Marshall was someone that I
have respected and someone I have admired
virtually my entire life.
But I can't agree with him that I want
all peremptory challenges eliminated.
And why do you think Thurgood Marshall
Justice Marshall when straight to no
perimeter?
I think Justice Marshall concluded that
he did not have faith in America to be
able to make these kinds of decisions.
And I understand why he concluded that.
And you do you have that faith?
I still do. And how long that
will last? I don't know. Hmm.
But I still do right now.
[inaudible]
Robinson says that to give up on these
peremptories is like giving up on who we
might be one day because
of who we are right now.
That's conceding that we are so divided
by race that we will never be able to
try and fix it. And I'm not
prepared to concede that
[inaudible]
okay. One last thing for my trip.
De Louisville told Joe,
Hey, what's up James?
All right. Close by something that
blew me away. I'm Joe Guttman.
I'm a teacher at central high
school, also an attorney at law,
James Batson, truck grabber
and construction worker.
Amongst other things.
I probably should add that I'm the
former prosecutor of Mr Bateson's cases.
Joe Guttman and James Batson.
Those two people whose conflict in a
courtroom back in 1983 gave us the Batson
rule. They are now in 2016.
Hmm. Friends. I've I've to
him about him. Yes, dude.
Yep. We're friends. All
right, let's do it. Yup. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad this is more
perfect miniseries about
the supreme court and, um,
today's story from a reporter.
Shawn, I always f up your last name.
Can you just say it? Ramez from
Ramas firm, I always put the accent,
the wrong place. Anyhow,
let me set the table for you. We
live in a representative democracy.
And what does that actually
mean? Practically speaking?
Like when do we come in contact with that?
Democracy to places seems to me
mainly one when we vote, right?
Yeah. You asking me? Yeah, I was deep
in thought, if you vote, if you vote.
It's true. I know like college educated,
super progressive human beings who
are like, why would I ever vote?
It doesn't mean anything. Exactly.
Not to mention people who just don't
even care about the world. Yeah.
It sort of makes my point like voting
is the first way and for a lot of people
it's entirely optional. The second right
away is not, you will be
fine if you don't do it.
And I mean serving on a
jury, this is where like we,
the people decide who goes
to jail, who gets free,
who lives, who dies.
This is where we actually
do democracy today. Uh,
we start with the story of a guy who
supreme, who is Supreme Court famous,
would you say? Yeah. He's in the
books. He's like a chapter. Yeah.
He's like one of the most important names
you've never heard of because he's at
the center of this ongoing battle about
who gets to serve on juries and his
name. Depending on who you are,
either symbolizes the best parts of
American democracy or the most cynical,
should I say his name? Yeah, go for
it. James Batson. James Kirkland.
That's, Hello
James Shot.
I went to his house and Norville tell me
your full name and tell me where you're
from and that James Batson,
Louisville, Kentucky, James Batson,
his name just kept coming up over and
over again when I was looking through the
history of jury selection in America.
So I called him up and I was like, Hey,
I'm this radio reporter in New York City
and I'm really interested in your case
because there's this other case
before the court right now.
Could I come talk to you? And he's,
he was like, Oh yeah, sure. Okay,
make sure my full name and shitty
mentioned. Of course he's tall.
He's built like a fridge. Um,
he's a black man. Drove truck,
local and cross country far
for business, 15 hours one way.
Where does that Florida as a kid,
he was, he was an aide student.
Graduated from her and technical
high school. Hughes, uh, you know,
like a vocational school specializing
in electrical engineering,
industrial electricity.
He seemed pretty popular.
[inaudible] perfect tennis water
Sunday school when I was 18,
but shortly after that it
seemed like the bottom fell out.
James Batson grew up in the West End of
Louisville in the 1970s and the west end
was super rough with people
selling dope prostitution. Uh,
everything had to do with
fast money at a young age.
Fast money was like,
oh, the American dream.
I mean it's pretty hard when a lot of
people round you got nice thing and they
got them because they're doing something
illegal and you keep calling up rabid.
Here you're shaking your
head like, you know what,
rabbit or [inaudible] you pull both
of your pockets and ain't nothing,
didn't need them. One of them, he
said it all started when he was 10.
He wanted a pair of shoes. He couldn't
afford them. Chuck Tyler's, well,
when I first came out, if you
didn't have a pair of those,
you hit on what they call buddies,
old buddies, cheap tennis shoes.
Him and his brother asked his mom for
the money and she gave them some money,
but not enough, so to
make up the difference.
They went out and they stole people's
empty soda bottles and turn them in for
like the deposits [inaudible] Nicola
piece stolen up pop bottles to get chuck
Taylors. There was my
first experience with.